support you're the guy with the big gun
the big noisy bipod mounted gun you lay
down long-range accurate fire you kill
sniper as you shut down infantry rushes
and you keep the ammo flowing you also
have trip mines which you can use to
cover your own objective Duff we have
lost objective Duff so how do you become
an effective support player in
battlefield one closed alpha we're here
to tell you for starters pick the lmg
that fits your play style you've got the
Lewis gun p.m. 1909 and the matteson mg
all of which come in by pod or salt
variants you acquire these with the war
bonds currency system bipod styles come
with optics which I personally prefer
but be aware if you roll with an AR
variant you can run a gun but you are
not special assault as better weapons in
you at close range
my personal favorite gun was the M 1909
which seemed to lay down the most
consistent and accurate long-range fire
I disliked the Lewis gun which has the
highest rate of fire but it's hard to
control even when feathering the
matteson generally has a bad sight
picture with that banana clip on top
when it comes to gear you're the ammo
guy give it to everybody all the time
scout on a ridge give it the salt player
sniping tanks give it did you throw a
grenade keep some for yourself you also
now have the high explosive trip mine
great for trapping entry and exit points
two objectives generally the trip wire
goes in the direction you're facing so
take note not so great against tanks
speaking of tanks when you run into one
look at your grenade inventory did you
pack a light anti-tank grenade no go
find a stationary again there's nothing
you can do as a matter of fact never
neglect vehicles or stationary weapons
around the battlefield they do a great
job of making up for your weaknesses
also don't try and open up walls with
grenades it doesn't work we've tried i
wound up settling on the gas grenade
because it distracts and damages enemies
and can double as a smoke grenade when
you're in a bind also when using a gas
mask players can't aim down sights
giving players with close range weapons
or high rate of fire guns the advantage
finally if you want to rack up a lot of
extra points either be a squad leader
and give objective orders or request
them constantly and that's about it for
the Alpha if you want more battlefield
one coverage hit that subscribe button
on YouTube and let us know what you
think of the world war one settings so
far in the comments below we'll see you
out on the battlefield
you